[Music]
Robert K. Durkee:
I can tell you that as an undergraduate, I
could never have imagined speaking from this
Robert K. Durkee:
stage, much less doing so in front of hundreds
of Princeton women.
[Laughter, clapping]
Shirley M. Tilghman:
We are gathered on this occasion to both look
back, to enjoy the present, and then to most
Shirley M. Tilghman:
importantly look forward to Princeton in the
future and the role that women will undoubtedly
Shirley M. Tilghman:
play in this University for the rest of time.
Diversity is an educational value at this University.
[Music]
Sonia Sotomayor:
Walking in through those front gates and looking
at Nassau Hall is bewitching and magical...
Sonia Sotomayor:
but in many ways it turned out to be the exactly
perfect place for me. And because I needed
Sonia Sotomayor:
to learn so much when I was here, and the
small personal environment that this University
Sonia Sotomayor:
then, and I believe even today, gave, I was
able to find professors who helped me grow.
Sonia Sotomayor:
And that is what catapulted me into the rest
of my life. Justice Stevens said it the best,
Sonia Sotomayor:
which is, in the job you should be growing, always.
[Music]
Wendy Kopp:
And I have to also thank Princeton for the
opportunities it afforded me. Taking me from a
Wendy Kopp:
bubble in Dallas, Texas, and exposing me
to the intellectual rigors of Princeton and
Wendy Kopp:
to a place where working hard was normal.
It took me a year to get over being part of
Wendy Kopp:
a student body and I don't know how many people
out there this resonates with, where being
Wendy Kopp:
motivated and driven was actually cool and
normal. To having the Woodrow Wilson School,
Wendy Kopp:
a place where I could pursue my passion of
solving real-world problems and, of course,
Wendy Kopp:
for the thesis requirement.
[Music]
Lisa Jackson:
We do have things in common. We need to find
them and outline where they are. And the aspiration to
Lisa Jackson:
test the limits, to go beyond where people
think we can be, is probably one of the first
Lisa Jackson:
things we all have in common. That's something
that brought us here to this extraordinary institution.
Lisa Jackson:
It's up to us to pass it on. Nothing
will inspire the next generation of
Lisa Jackson:
women leaders like the example of this generation
and we set that example.
[Music]
Andrea Jung:
Leadership, women and Princeton have all really
collided into what I think is an amazing inflection
Andrea Jung:
point. Compassion is an equal, extraordinarily
important facet of great leadership and I
Andrea Jung:
believe in that hallmark very much. You can't
reinvent your company until you reinvent yourself.
Andrea Jung:
So, it was a great piece of advice and I share
it with you because I think, for all of us --
Andrea Jung:
women, men alike -- I think this concept
of continual reinvention is what allows me
Andrea Jung:
to be able to be in a job for a decade, which
allows a company to be here for 125 years,
Andrea Jung:
which allows enormously successful institutions
like this to be here 250 years and plus. So,
Andrea Jung:
the thought is at every aspect of life, but
it does start from an individual basis,
Andrea Jung:
in terms of just that very, very liberating but
very, very disciplined constant transformation
Andrea Jung:
and reinvention of yourself.
[Music]